am I doing here what am I doing here
he'll know what I'm doing here plan
elopement Mar that choose a show say
well I am blocking dad why is having the
slutting that Erica okay anyways we're
about to start episode two house able to
connect with thousands of players now
thank you
the last thing I want to do is connect
okay startup so - yeah here's what
happened last episode we no way now okay
you've told us
she took our wearing off please let me
do the dishes that's the least I could
do
now I'm crashing here Crashers claim
vicious here's a family be fine if
they're not clean the right way David
becomes with the baby about at all he's
gonna [ __ ] her I'm a pro at this point
no no I insist
grab the sponge and you're gonna be
eating it too it's not a big deal yes
right kiss her no I know you don't mind
but I won't be here for too long just
you know gotta get back on my feet a
little you're right
I don't mind but Dean was is that it
maybe a little bit actually forget I
said that
oh that wasn't for me - just forget it
sorry he's always talking about how I'm
never around then when I'm actually here
he acts like he doesn't know me it's
complicated but look he loves you
you're his brother he's got an odd way
of showing it so where do you think
he'll go don't know what what happened
in your pan I'd be amazed if I could get
a job assistant coaching t-ball you'll
land on your feet here's hoping I could
use a fresh start now I'll probably just
travel around you know see what's out
there want to take me with you
well Kate come on but you know that's a
bad idea
of course I do I'm just messing around
what it's just hard to say no to a fresh
start I always wanted to go to Norway
see them Northern Lights
you'll be jet-setting and I'll still
just be here oh my god she's so clumsy
cuz remember one oh I was give its army
glass he's gonna be so pissy about it I
can hear him already
oh it's so annoying blame me when he'll
buy it I'm the idiot [ __ ] right that's
true exactly
Oh God
kiss our kisser much better what was
that noise
guys hold on hold on baby
hello David like you [ __ ] my woman my
CEO gave me that and unless you want to
dig up his [ __ ] corpse you're not
gonna give me another why don't we get
an actual dishwater here we go again
then you won't be on my ass anytime
there's a spot on a fork excuse me if we
could even afford a dishwasher David
come on take it easy
there's an accident until you step away
and cool off we will see your ass for a
year a year then when your life goes to
[ __ ] we're expected to drop everything
and roll out the red carpet all for
Prince javi and now you're gonna start
telling me how to talk to my wife this
isn't about him really he's the one
standing right there judging me for
something he doesn't understand this guy
I don't like I do
tell them all no no David time come on
open your eyes
hopefully rise badge Eve your ass what
she told us you holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] christ no we were talking about
traveling and I just know I definitely
didn't say that at all three days then I
want you off my couch and out the door
we clear fine every hobby that is my
husband we are married in case you
forgot that's for life oh [ __ ] you're
gonna kiss Sarah what sure
alright [ __ ] that one up a little bit
ah just quit smoking earlier ogre is
[ __ ] disgusting
no thanks - hey take it easy what
happened they got away yeah we got a
couple of their friends in Haryana oh
yeah so what happens realistic could set
tapes too much I already dug a grave for
her no thanks [ __ ] I mean look at her
let me look at her hole or a bullet hole
not her
that's disgusting she's a kid alright
say you guys let this be a reminder this
is what happens when you smoke wait even
a single puff of weed can do this to you
did you see this yep yep Shane dad
listen here's a reefer it's sad because
this isn't the first sin it it won't be
the last
but good a lot of other reefers will die
the same way yeah nice aid shed just
bear that [ __ ] let's keep God burning
daylight
come on javi let's just cover her up
that barrier a lot javi what
thank you for staying I think you
probably saved my life okay well nice
Raven I'll have to use a [ __ ] car any
more
I should have gone with them no we
slowed them down and now they'll come
back for us right I I don't know maybe
maybe maybe it's always maybe that's
espera this betcha gate keep God tape
liar leave his cassette flying on a sec
yeah throw her in there
she carried this around for years
I don't you want to just [ __ ] lay it
on her maybe next to her you hit why to
Josh Anna okay take the take bit take
the batteries out okay Jesus can this be
automated like what's going on
[ __ ] it is every time I'm sorry I never
found you those candy corns
if [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was covered that
eat the candy wise now so much more life
hmm he's just upset he can't listen a
pendant on his tax forms at anymore and
get it you should have been the one bury
me some some day ah some be far away
I well done it done so okay everything
you possibly once use a shovel so let
one guy and crying what is this
I can't remember that's like one of the
people that can happen what has I don't
do anything what I use a [ __ ] bullet
for that okay the other guys had this -
Shh
what what's wrong Clem I run into these
guys before who are they
please
they call themselves the new frontier I
used to be decent people now they're
something else
oh this brand they have it's like an
initiation thing I was kind of stuck in
their camp for a while not by choice
it was bad I'm lucky to be alive would
you do to piss them off you do kind of
have a temper sometimes I got out that's
all that matters it was one of their
cars behind that's something at least
good just like you always wanted
well I feel like so pissed off at her I
can take you back to Prescott make sure
your family's okay but then I'm hitting
the road alright suit yourself
good luck out there Clem thanks javi we
should get back to Prescott
I'm gonna take a shovel like why do I
leave tools are Alex Chet is if they're
going to find another shovel [ __ ]
lucky they found a shovel right there so
I said oh you're back
my family did Eleanor get them here okay
she did though okay isn't the word I'd
use to describe him Eleanor's been doing
what she can you best get over the
infirmary
[ __ ] he didn't catch that [ __ ] how
she's pest she asked for you you know
please please just tell me how she's
doing well
she came through the surgery as well as
could be expected those bastards in her
one favor at least any lower and that
bullet would have torn her stomach
lining as well
look at that [ __ ] your boy game he seems
really fierce he wanted to help so badly
he practically forced me to let him stay
thanks Gabe but she was bleeding so much
he got overwhelmed [ __ ] he can't do
anything rash you're gonna be up on her
feet again she's stable for now but
she's still bleeding inside
chicer I don't lie to you it's probably
just a matter of time I
I wish I could do more thanks for trying
and for not sugarcoating it wish I had
something better to tell you but I'm
sorry javi I'm going to get cleaned up
you may want to find Gabe you're like
pretty upset when he left
yes I didn't make him feel any better
still can't touch me click off Setter I
grabbed a she looks [ __ ] best though
now where's the where's the [ __ ] lady
I just I'll talk to my [ __ ] wife I
guess I can't gather that not that again
oh yeah what a while
thank you
[ __ ] install it thank you out look at
[ __ ] that waste my time who the fool
shitty the wallah doesn't look super
sturdy that's just kidding
hey you seen a kid coming through here
blood all over his hands dog look on his
face headed out that way without saying
word how are you
I give him some space just my advice one
parent to another out of the year right
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't need your
advice shut the [ __ ] up you two on the
hill honest yeah good I take it that
wasn't his that was has his stepmoms you
got to stay strong for her do whatever
it takes
no of my friend seal in the same
situation I fight like hell anything we
can do to help you out let me know kind
of naturally has that tact appreciate
that
yeah stomped all towards the front gate
ah
what the [ __ ] c-come on look at me
I want to go back and bury Mariana we
buried her it was peaceful what could it
have been peaceful and I said I know how
much you miss her Gabe I miss her too
Kinkaid she needed me during her surgery
she needed my help
okay ran away like a stupid little kid
you should say right you should have
stayed yeah [ __ ] love you bad you
need you back down and you you I you
just watch that back there yes I know it
just it just lost it and not an excuse
not anymore
I'm done feeling this way feeling
powerless
I can't be some helpless little boy
anymore I need to be a man just like my
dad what if there was a [ __ ] after
all supposed to hey I'm the one who's
supposed to take care of you guys
yeah and look what a good job you did
better I'm dad I'm not gonna sit back
and watch I'm gonna do something I have
to listen Gabe okay
your father's an [ __ ] okay there's
your chance the proof at fetch
[ __ ] get shy can gab we might have to
leave make sure Kate's ready you can
count on me about time I'll [ __ ] up this
time cat
now clementines feel that your ass out
knock-knock anyone home we know them
those are the freaks that brand
themselves I wish we hadn't had to come
all the way out here but unfortunately
badger here says you attacked his man he
says you fired on has cost a lot of our
people [ __ ] if anything they
attacked us oh please
we were just defending ourselves you
know what you did how many of my friends
died because of you huh a lot sounds
like a budget he said she said [ __ ] to
me what the [ __ ] do you want an apology
what I really want for my good buddies
to be alive again
but I don't think that's too likely is
it usually a say answer to justice
except just punishment [ __ ] that go [ __ ]
yourself this is option sir go [ __ ]
yourself animals go [ __ ] yourselves
hey [ __ ] from us dead gadget ain't
bulletproof don't make me prove it back
to the matter is you stole from us you
killed some of us give it up now and get
down here I think they need a little
incentive let's say
there's that hate this [ __ ] you hard-on
I'll kill you whoa you didn't tell me
you had a hostage don't be okay baby I
love you bro night baby yes
just give them what they want first dad
no reason this ass to get ugly I can't
do it
she doesn't mean anything to me
[ __ ] I hear you loud and clear
get the finger up Oh
get your ass down here we're not the
rest of them
what's that hell are you doing Bobby
please man just just don't with him you
got to you kill France the old body's
giving in to them you should start
shooting we don't negotiate with
terrorists you Cooper see okay I got
let's do this [ __ ] let's do this
Schatz side
perfect
[ __ ] oh what the [ __ ]
we don't have to go hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you go ahead ran the [ __ ] gate dig a
deep breath
thanks now it looks like I'm causing a
lot of turmoil my side but that's how
its falling apart over my crazy gorilla
sector Nick right you're gonna kiss me
[ __ ]
[ __ ] tear gas [ __ ] tear gas I have
to find Katie can you help us go man
I'll hold these [ __ ] off
that's a man that's a boy that's our boy
okay they're gonna take a knife or what
Bobby okay
[ __ ] that doesn't upper bar you got
it bro right okay
head east we'll catch up shut all right
you might say episode set that you
[ __ ] took the wall for this one
I'm on the mystery man bed really [ __ ]
up that town anything she's like hey
what's going on here just napping and I
guess Gasquet objects and water
laughs
shut ok ties that bottom part so ok it's
just my shorts for this one yeah chase
always JS lies Nina says what penis does
are they following it I just the other
car looks like we're ok so I don't know
who I'm gonna bang in the Belle Noel
lure or Kate I can't tell I mean I
activate both of them but no no no
what's gonna happen
Eleanor thank God I can't believe it
all of our friends all those people uh
Who am I to this band we got no choice
nice ain't shet piece of [ __ ]
good one who open fire she's dead
because of you laughs rad easy buddy
this wasn't his fault
[ __ ] Francine Prescott all because
this washed-up cheap walk through our
gates should have known it the second I
looked at you back to hell I bet you Hey
hi everybody calm down
justice I [ __ ] a batch up Clark and
Conrad please Conrad with if it wasn't
for him back the [ __ ] off now
just back away take it easy son
kid put down the gun just do it already
I don't even care anymore just put it
down Gabe come on kid
I said [ __ ] Gabe don't I want to see if
he's man enough what the [ __ ]
don't touch my uncle again okay let him
go he just needs to cool off huh
now nice job there hobby Thanks yeah
this guy we gotta get rid of this guy
he's just gonna slow us down I use up
resources now that's a [ __ ] outta here
he's faking it
you're second you have to go back you
have to [ __ ] at the fact I could but
Prescott's overrun we can't go back
well we're not safe here either what
about Richmond I've heard there's a
community there if it's true they'll
have food balls maybe even a hospital
what I want is to find the [ __ ]
who did this - don't talk about this is
how they make Sultan we took mom god
damn it
yeah I know
it keeps dying if there's even a chance
for her in Richmond I need to take it
that's what I talked about boy huh
that's what I'm talking about yeah [ __ ]
it let's go file a beard say if I lie
got this guy in pop my hands
huh maybe they'll hit it off hope so
might be good for them both they need
someone their own age they can talk to
him come on guys
a long drive ahead of us I don't give a
[ __ ] I remember that and not do my
driving still I should shove it
yes that do for you here I just I feel
like I'm burning up
I'm dying of thirst hi got looking at
that water bottle here you go
I gotta kiss this [ __ ] before she
perishes that's for sure
thirsty isn't good how's your forehead
feel her kiss oh sorry for it hot hot
it's probably sepsis sooner we get to
Richmond the better oh they're really
hurt I can't lose you
not now and I don't want to leave you
but Wow
Bobby we both know what's coming what me
your panties we do and this is gonna
sound [ __ ] up but guess what maybe
this is my chance for Christ I don't
know
graceful exit they said that [ __ ] up -
you don't get to just bow out
I need you betcha think about all that
happened
Mariama died I couldn't stop it and gave
I heard what happened when we stopped
and that obvious about what what I might
be turning into David he might be
turning into you he's not that sweet
little boy I first met he just needs
guidance and a lot of it
and I hope so all I care about is him
becoming who he needs to be which is
gonna be on you to make sure that
happens
no ma'am I'm not buying this I'm dying
[ __ ] it's on both of us you're buying it
whether you want to or not oh hey
careful careful
- you should get some rest Kate we also
really with pleasure
kiss our parents just love pretending
the rest of us came here that's it
what Eric's drugging what's going on did
you touch your himself that is [ __ ] up
if you touched yourself oh my god that
is [ __ ] up
then later the tell-tale like that now
I'm not we're going Jean you penis me
once shame on you okay miss me twice
shame on ray great what now
I've got some bad news that's got a lot
going on well guess we got a bunch of
cars clogging the underpass too many to
drive through we're gonna need to move
some of them out of the way hey I'm
coming too I gotta talk to the chef Kate
and keep a lookout yeah what else if
anything happens awfully convenient the
pass is blocked like this not convenient
at all if you ask me
how about sex objects at all right there
we should be good come on let's get to
work and clear it out just one car trip
that's it
I'm not gonna be able to push it by
myself can I nope no wheels
bro I don't want to talk to this [ __ ]
and eásá here
good good
that is this yeah [ __ ] miss custom
they kept
we need to power it somehow
I don't want to turn it on do I it's got
to be a way to power this thing I'll
look around
Fraser wrench on six and a half about
nice now I can plug the cable hopefully
that'll hold still need something to
power this bumpy yeah pop a hot talker
fetch how are we doing and Conrad
doesn't look too good over there tell me
about it
he's a good man hobby known him a long
time this is just a dark day for him
yeah he's keep an eye on him for me
alright looked at okay anything over
here I could use all these wires down
you know [ __ ] up this guy's day who's
that Gabe [ __ ] cuz I'm talking you know
it's getting the [ __ ] out of here
those might come in handy
let me say I could [ __ ] up his day
actual Oh more I wanna [ __ ] this [ __ ]
up you good nah man I'm not good I know
let's just get this [ __ ] over with and
get to Richmond yeah bad conversation I
thought okay
I shouldn't disturb her she's resting
pop the hood
you should better not mess up my baby
here that'll do
Aldo Peck here goes nothing
hey here we go second half we good
be ready to move once the wreck is clear
we should be right behind you will do
get the walkers she said [ __ ] hey
Eleanor now go go go
just try get it a Richmond right behind
you
they're through let's go fucking-a yeah
you read Cal let's fetch Thanks
[ __ ] man [ __ ] Oh God we got bigger
problems here the roof go come on [ __ ]
come on back go [ __ ] that's pretty loud
I guess
come on come on bro
why is Conrad like trying to save my
[ __ ] tell us a lot
god damn it I knew this place didn't
feel right what the hell are we gonna do
now
Conrad you gotta go out there we have to
come up with some kind of plan oh what a
great idea
okay Ryan who would have thought of that
we don't have a choice we got to fight
our way out nuts whoo I like our odds
great this is just [ __ ] great what
the hell are we gonna do calm down calm
down I'm not gonna [ __ ] calm down
Eleanor's out there alone right now you
wouldn't even be in this mess everyone
for you not true
[ __ ] you Connor I don't stop there's
somebody over there what we're [ __ ]
everybody get down there's a [ __ ] ever
there was a solar trap
keep your heads down guy could have a
rifle I don't know about the rest of you
but I like to keep my skull intact
show yourself what the hell he's gone
everyone stay here and keep behind
cockin spider-man I'm gonna see what I
can find out be careful
I would not be worrying about that
person if I were you
what's happening out
let me show up for there with the [ __ ]
over there oh my face it's dry
this session it was a special fire he
dumped the manor woman OH
it's a fake
I think you killed that but it'd be a
shame if somebody real had to die now
then I'm not gonna shoot not unless you
make me I just want to talk
who is your thicker just want to have a
word put the gun down
that wouldn't be very smart of me with
it you the two guys they're the kids the
women in the car I saw you split up I
overheard that little argument just now
your friends over there aren't gonna
shoot me right you folks have your [ __ ]
together you want to know whether
they'll shoot you keep pointing that gun
at me a couple more questions then we're
done you're going to Richmond that tells
me you got something to do with what's
going on down there
question is whose side are you want look
man I don't love it okay let's just kill
this [ __ ] okay don't move
well you see one of them hey man what do
you mean by them whose then you know
what I'm talking about the new frontier
what no I'm not with those guys you got
this backwards Bobby this guy's full of
Donkey [ __ ] do you want to let me talk
what's the point how can we trust
anything you say he's been watching us I
know that much it's not like that it got
it like I don't approach anyone I don't
already know I had to be sure you people
were level-headed clearly I was wrong he
got the brand up look I'm telling you
I'm on my way to Richmond just like you
I lost touch with some good people there
when the new frontier took oh yeah he's
too quick of a talker
Rick Ellis guy what did you say the new
frontier they took over Richmond don't
tell me you didn't know that [ __ ] oh god
Eleanor Kate they're headed right to the
middle of those [ __ ]
at least now we got an excuse to go
after they playin us
you better not be lying us I'm not and I
can prove it there's an old train tunnel
that runs under the James River from
what I hear it should be a straight shot
into Richmond a train tunnel I could
lead you guys there and I know you're
all having trust issues today but maybe
you could lower those guns first no way
right letting my ass we're going to tie
you up and make sure your story checks
out
that's really not necessary
find his hands let's tie this patch up
better safe than sorry
whatever you say mm-hmm whatever I said
[ __ ] okay
not ready this way hey what do we call
you Claire sorry forgot to introduce
myself
it's Paul but my friends call me Jesus I
think Jesus character the new season
Walking Dead not great this [ __ ] having
flashbacks again
let's get doesn't make it obviously so
we can hide in here huh sigh sigh sigh
don't worry it's gonna be ok just fish
gonna start talking oh you didn't work
so let me try to seamen I want to call
him cement ok I just note that keep
seeming safe see much yourself [ __ ] up
yeah you're hungry cover a sucking math
you [ __ ] [ __ ] we're gonna wait for
them to go then then we're gonna find
you some dinner hopefully find Oh some
dinner
alright guys hate em ok I can hear you
in there honey in please
how is that mess yeah let her
hey there hello pretty big group you
heard any bites no no way show you what
helps us fish out this lady is ghetto
ass [ __ ] I say we make a pretty good
team
ah not really but okay why would you say
that I guess - that's right bus I mean
yeah seems like we do things like it huh
mmm you can't talk about guys living
here Earth is running out to be a mom
14:13 I knew his parents but they're
gone now I'm all he had and he's cute
and lucky he has someone looking after
not much about anymore who is this
better out there scouting nothing out of
the ordinary isn't ordinary inant
khaosan Shh those bastards are slow but
god damn it when there's enough of them
I got separated from the others god I
hope they all made it worth us thought
we were ready for anything
what were you scouting for gas water oh
I bet his new frontier sure as hell was
worth it and that's how sue probably
guys let's dock me I know it she's
covered neck
by the way I'm Ava and my group we call
ourselves and you sent to you heck
all right hungry hey why don't you come
meet my people my food blankets bottled
water I'll - music come on dinner's on
me groups aren't really my thing
no woman is an island that's what is
that okay we're good she just rolled her
eyes but you did me a solid here I won't
forget it next time we cross paths there
is no next time killer fee the world
does work in mysterious ways
teller
hey this these tunnels had decades ago
but I've heard you can get through yours
open guys change stories changed a
little bit hobby I need to talk to you
well look I appreciate you keeping quiet
about me in the new frontier what I told
you earlier it's not the whole truth
she's the new frontier she's the queen
okay so tell me oh I should told you
soon hmm I I really should have you were
with those lobsters they're not all like
that I'm not asking you to forgive me
but you have to understand I had nobody
I was all alone I thought I didn't need
them but they were very persuasive
all right I really give a [ __ ] and I'm
in now so I doesn't matter it was a
mistake and so was not telling you about
it tell me you're not still one of them
no way
believe me but I just had to explain
because they're really in control in
Richmond I can't let them see me I just
can't
what you don't reach the other side of
this tunnel I'm leaving y'all planning
on doing enough just second [ __ ] Conner
I do you were to watch your mouth where
I clear with again you all hear that
I'm going over there can you see
anything
they're everywhere why they are keep
sharp like when I say stuff like that
like [ __ ] yeah
Oh help
happy soaping anything you think that's
all what the [ __ ]
take him out everywhere oh mighty Conrad
doesn't matter the [ __ ] County is
gonna be heading this one on follow me
and this guy's got more Walker's in like
[ __ ] any other one I did gotta find a
way around it we're [ __ ] dinner maybe
we can just go through well does it open
what if I just don't think refastening I
got it come on hey lights ahead big
[ __ ] god where's Felicia I was just
following javi and I will block the door
you guys go ahead and make sure it's
clear I get fast
we'll be right ahead of you saying how
about it's a special the door shut well
I can find something a barricade weary
I'm gonna have to break this thing off
they're almost here you like that baby
you like that baby okay okay we got it
I wouldn't touch that gun girl
you either cowboy how are you doing
without Zach you think I'm stupid
- your little story now we we need to
keep moving you need to talk
Conrad this is crazy gravy is you cover
fire roll up the damned sleeve ah he
heard that conversation like I [ __ ]
knew you wanted a draw down right after
hitting now at what other [ __ ] did
you shove down our throat huh Jesus
Conrad lower the [ __ ] gun this is in
essence Orin you're missing the bigger
picture son don't you see we bring her
to Richmond they'll give us whatever we
want medical help for Kate
she's our bargaining [ __ ] they won't
bargain with you you don't know them
know until we try she's not a bargaining
chip she's a friend Oh draw the gun we
got a Kelvin bet she would just soul
mates care that's Bastion answer
go to hell Conrad I'm not doing this you
want to shoot me shoot me while I shoot
- no boys granny is here there's a
little one for that door easy no I like
Gabe so I guess I was gotta be and then
we all step into the sunshine come on
man be reasonable
we should there we go see that's this is
how we do things up in this show it okay
this is how we do things you should go
what about you I'll find my own way all
right what's your honored so this is the
brightest timeline cuz it just happened
so fast again I mean on Gabriel okay
let's go [ __ ] let's go yeah there
Ganassi where's Conrad I'm gonna say he
didn't make it he had suffered MP just
remember it he had a whole bunch of
plans he had to get done
where's Conrad hidden they cannot make
it out he's he's gone he didn't make it
out sorry so that's it he just oh man
Conrad [ __ ] trying to stay quiet [ __ ]
Christ
dammit Conrad and the girl where is she
or should we assume the worst she ran
off I just don't know what the hell is
going on anymore yeah what a [ __ ] show
this isn't what any of us wanted but
right now we need to find king shark
like strength a nice time I don't get it
I mean I really [ __ ] up his [ __ ]
town and everything you're right I just
wish what what do you wish what is it
honey wish to [ __ ]
now [ __ ] there's a wish the gates are
this way if your people are here that's
where they would ended up why is it so
quiet thought there'd be new frontier
marching in the streets and [ __ ]
practicing on walk oh this is it
whatever the [ __ ] they do it does seem
strangely quiet maybe we just got lucky
ah [ __ ] did they see us I don't think so
you see we're gonna take all this way to
[ __ ] town that's the quarry keep it
down keep shut the [ __ ] up
okay take can you hear me
Kate talk to me
say something javi yes could really use
something to take the edge off right
about now
well kiss her oh she scared the hell out
of me she likes that Kate are you who
are you okay come here
where's Eleanor she she went ahead to
get help
she hasn't come back damaged it must
have got her
Jesus how far is it to their compound
not too much farther now a couple blocks
at most
Gabe help me lift her up didn't ever
check his earth
I'm thinking Kate's not gonna make it
much longer so it's time we walk up to
the front door and say hello all right
fine
here we go mm-hmm
your ends here going to be a big ship
shell and I was going to end
there it is New Richmond well take is
like fake join everything I'm gonna get
you inside okay javi if he can save me
how about you if you finally take that
trip to Norway the night and night
remember sky lit up all green and purple
as long as we make some time to hit the
slopes I mean this guy's got a kisser
Jesus there's a solid possibility this
isn't gonna go our way if you want to
stay behind I wouldn't blame you
hey this is where I was going in the
first place how is she bet you subscribe
your frontier holy [ __ ] you again you
watch that so Colin yeah needs medical
help and you have one of our people
uh-huh what's your point after what you
did to our people I'm not inclined to
help any of you I know we both got a
bone to pick here but we can hash that
out later she needs to get to the
hospital or she's gonna die then I guess
she's gonna die but what a bet it was
your men that shot her your bullets you
owe it to us to help now we don't owe
you [ __ ] it's got nothing to do with me
your people your problems she dies I'm
holding you personally responsible just
cause you say something doesn't make it
so please Kate's done she needs help
star like I don't have a heart okay but
your people started this whole [ __ ]
staying in the first place let's not
forget what you did it probably not what
you did to our home
Prescott right that whole situation was
a damn man it happened it's over nothing
I can do about it now my niece is dead
you know you owe us this
he's got a little heart all of you lower
your weapons might be a good idea to
play along here at least for now you put
him down I'll see that as an expression
of good faith nice and easy
everybody that's got the gun down i I
just need to kiss Kay preach that you're
the boss yeah okay hands behind your
heads
oli we let them do this it's over we
can't give them another inch
cat for Kate okay
now get on your knees if he was gonna
kill us I think if you'd done it by you
hear me I said me
yes you were serious about this after
all
yeah hey what the hell is going on out
here they said they weren't here to hurt
anybody so I was trying to see if they
oh my god
what da [ __ ] Doge away holy [ __ ] now
that is a lot to us okay baby
gently yes
yes oh
very few people select a tie jesus' them
together okay wait countdown Wow a lot
of people gave it it's good okay very
good
very good
hmm okay well how's a good episode
thanks for watching y'all and then we'll
see y'all on the next enter k will say
y'all the next one okay thank ya